* Unheilvolle Musik *
* Melancholische Klänge,
abgehacktes Stöhnen *
Wenn eine Krankheit
unser Leben bestimmt.
Wenn wir ihr ausgeliefert sind:
Welche Risiken
wären wir bereit einzugehen,
wenn uns eine Operation
ein normales Leben schenken könnte?
Würden wir akzeptieren,
mit unserer Krankheit zu leben -
oder alles aufs Spiel setzen?
Wenn wir ein Ziel
so klar vor Augen haben
und wir die Hoffnung
nicht aufgeben können.
Welche Entscheidung
würden wir treffen?
* Schwere Klavierklänge *
Morgen ist ...
... der wichtigste Tag
meines Lebens, kann man sagen.
Morgen ist der Tag,
an welchem endlich die dritte und
definitive Operation stattfindet.
Sie wird entscheidend sein.
Mit den Ärzten ist alles gut
besprochen. Man weiss, es ist ...
Sie geben ihr Bestes,
es ist nicht alles in ihrer Macht.
Gewisse Dinge werden Schicksal sein,
aber ...
Fachlich sind das Topchirurgen.
Sie geben ihr Bestes
und ich vertraue und hoffe.
* Er lacht. *
Das ist ein mega Zufall.
Das Buch: "Letzte Runde".
Das ist wirklich sehr passend, ja.
Hoffentlich
ist das ein gutes Zeichen.
Dies ist die Geschichte von Nicola.
Eine Geschichte, geprägt
von zermürbendem Kontrollverlust
und dem unbändigen Wunsch
nach einem selbstbestimmten Leben.
* Eine Frau lacht. *
Er hatte immer ein starkes Mundwerk.
Er hat immer geplappert
und nachgemacht.
Zu Beginn wollte er
immer Sportreporter werden.
Und ...
Er hat Walter Scheibli
dermassen imitiert.
Er hat Gesellschaften, Besuch,
den wir hatten, unterhalten
und alle lachten. Er war immer der
Clown, auch was die Gestik anging.
Einfach ein sehr fröhliches
und aktives Kind.
Wir benutzten ihn als Agenda.
Er hatte
ein unglaublich gutes Gedächtnis.
Konnte man etwas nicht gleich
aufschreiben, sagte man es Nicola.
Und er wusste das auch noch
ein halbes Jahr später.
Die vierköpfige Familie
mit Vater Tschili und Bruder Sven
ahnte damals noch nicht,
was auf sie zukommen wird.
Schon sehr früh,
noch in der Unterstufe der Schule
habe ich gemerkt, dass es
im Alltag so kurze Zeiten ...
Ich beschrieb es mit:
"Mir wird es wie blöd im Kopf."
Plötzlich konnte er
nicht mehr lesen.
Das war sehr einschneidend,
weil es vorher funktionierte.
Und von einem Tag auf den anderen
ging es nicht mehr.
Ich erinnere mich an den
ersten Anfall, den ich gesehen habe.
Nicola ist von der Schule
nach Hause gekommen.
Er ist am Tisch gesessen,
wollte ein Glas Wasser nehmen
und ist einfach
in der Bewegung verharrt.
Das dauerte ein paar Sekunden.
Dann hat er dort weiter gemacht,
wo er aufgehört hat.
Da wusste ich, was er mit
"doof im Kopf werden" meinte.
Nach weiteren sichtbaren
Bewusstseinsstörungen, sog. Absenzen,
wird Nicola im Alter von zehn Jahren
im Kinderspital Zürich abgeklärt.
Zuerst dachten sie,
es könnte ein Hirntumor sein.
Ja, da schluckt man zuerst einmal
leer und denkt: "Wow, Hirntumor!"
Dann kam zum Glück
die Diagnose Epilepsie.
Man hat erst einmal aufgeatmet
und gedacht:
"Es ist ja schon mal gut."
Wir wussten natürlich nicht,
was noch alles kommt.
* Tief dröhnende, flackernde Musik *
Sie bewirkt einen Kurzschluss
im Gehirn -
und ist eine der häufigsten neurolo-
gischen Erkrankungen: Epilepsie.
Bei einem gesunden Menschen
ist das Zusammenspiel
von Milliarden von Nervenzellen
in unserem Gehirn
genau aufeinander abgestimmt.
Bei einem epileptischen Anfall
ist dieses Gleichgewicht
kurzzeitig gestört.
Viele Nervenzellen entladen sich
plötzlich gleichzeitig.
Diese Entladungen reizen einzelne
Gehirngebiete oder das ganze Gehirn.
* Elektrisches Flimmern *
Epilepsie
kann genetisch bedingt sein,
als Folge von
Stoffwechselerkrankungen
oder bei Veränderungen
der Hirnstruktur entstehen:
etwa bei Tumoren, Infektionen,
Blutgerinnseln
oder als Folge eines Unfalls.
Bei mehr als der Hälfte der Fälle
lässt sich die Ursache
aber nicht genau erklären.
In der Schweiz
sind etwa 80'000 Menschen betroffen.
(Frau) Sie hat den Titel
"Die heilige Krankheit",
"Das Ergriffenwerden".
Wenn ich mir die Patienten anschaue,
was sie im Leben macht,
ist eigentlich dieses
Unvorhersehbare das Schwierigste
oder der Kontrollverlust.
Man kann nicht bestimmen,
wann es kommt.
Was bedeutet es für den Einzelnen,
sein Leben, seine Lebensgestaltung,
wenn dann immer wieder
vielleicht ein Unterbruch
oder dieser Autonomieverlust kommt?
Es ist natürlich
alles viel komplizierter geworden.
Da und dort musste man sagen:
"Du darfst das nicht mehr machen!",
z.B. schwimmen.
Rad fahren ging auch nicht mehr.
Und, selbst hat man natürlich
immer Angst.
Das ist seit dem ersten Moment so.
Man steht unter Dauerangst.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Rund zwei Drittel
der an Epilepsie erkrankten Menschen
können mit Medikamenten
erfolgreich behandelt werden.
Oft gestaltet sich die Suche
nach einem wirksamen Medikament
jedoch als schwierig -
teils endet die Suche auch erfolglos.
All die Medikamente, die wir
nacheinander ausprobiert hatten,
hatten eher Nebenwirkungen
als Wirkungen.
Die Anfälle sind schlimmer geworden,
teilweise sogar häufiger.
Am Schlimmsten war,
dass sie unangenehmer wurden.
Auch diese Wesensveränderung ...
Er war nicht mehr
der fröhliche Nicola.
Teilweise sass er
nur noch traurig im Zimmer
und starrte Löcher in die Luft.
Ich habe mich fast etwas geschämt,
wenn ich vor meinen Kollegen
einen Anfall hatte.
Nicolas Anfälle können mit
Medikamenten nicht verhindert werden.
Die EPI-Klinik in Zürich bietet in
diesen schwierigen Fällen Hilfe an.
Im Zuweisungsbrief stand,
dass er maximal zwölf Tage pro Monat
ohne Anfall war.
Er wurde uns relativ früh,
also nach einem Jahr,
von den Kollegen des Kinderspitals
zugewiesen.
Sie fragten, ob man Nicola nicht
durch eine Operation helfen könne.
Der zehnjährige Nicola
bleibt während einer Woche
in einem sog. Langzeit-EEG
in der EPI-Klinik.
Dazu muss er Tag und Nacht
im Bett bleiben,
während seine Hirnströme
mithilfe von Oberflächenelektroden
aufgezeichnet werden.
(Frau) Wiederhole das Wort Wolke.
Was ist das?
Möchtest du auch nicht?
Da die Epilepsieherde jedoch nicht
genau lokalisiert werden können,
schlagen die Ärzte der Familie vor,
mithilfe eines operativen Eingriffs
Elektroden zu implantieren.
Die Elektroden
ermöglichen eine genaue Lokalisierung
des Anfallsursprungs,
sodass die Epilepsieherde
chirurgisch entfernt werden könnten.
Zu der Zeit war ich jung.
Ich hatte Angst vor einer Operation.
* Surren, Hämmern *
Ich war von Anfang an sicher -
eine Operation: nein.
Sie erklärten,
wie so eine Operation ablaufen würde
und was alles gemacht würde.
Das war für uns schrecklich,
weil ...
Man taucht
in eine ganz andere Welt ein,
wenn man Hirnoperation hört,
Elektroden implantieren ...
Im ersten Moment denkt man,
dass man danach tot ist.
Das kann gar nicht gehen.
In diesem Alter konnte ich mir
überhaupt nicht vorstellen,
das über mich ergehen zu lassen.
Wir fanden ...
Wir konnten nicht entschieden,
ein gesundes Kind ...
... am Hirn operieren zu lassen,
mit dem Risiko,
dass etwas schiefgehen könnte
und wir wären am Ende schuld,
dass es noch schlimmer wäre.
Das konnten wir nicht.
(Ärztin) Oft müssen die Eltern
für ihr Kind entscheiden.
Das geht oft erst,
wenn die Eltern ganz sicher sind,
dass der Nutzen deutlich höher ist
als das Risiko einer Operation.
Da muss man solange miteinander
sprechen und begleiten,
bis man, bis die Betroffenen
zur Überzeugung kommen,
dass es jetzt
die richtige Entscheidung ist.
* Lockere Gitarrenklänge *
Gemeinsam entscheidet sich die
Familie also gegen eine Operation.
Eine völlig andere Entscheidung aber
trifft Nicola ganz alleine.
Ich habe Polymechaniker gesehen.
Ich war begeistert davon.
Ich war fest davon überzeugt,
dass ich diesen Beruf machen möchte.
Als Polymechaniker
stellt man sich einen Menschen vor,
offen, mit grossen Kräften.
Und ich? Was passiert
bei einem Epilepsieanfall?
Als Mutter habe ich sofort rot
gesehen, als du damit gekommen bist.
Eine Maschine! Er fällt rein.
Für mich war der Fall klar:
Das geht nie!
Weil mein Mann auch das gelernt
hatte, wusste er in etwa,
wo man sich informieren musste.
Nicolas Vater trifft Abklärungen,
ob sein Sohn nicht doch
seinen Traumberuf ausüben könnte.
Mein Mann telefonierte
mit dem Berufsinspektor.
Der war sofort Feuer und Flamme und
meinte: "Geht nicht, gibt's nicht!"
Den Zeitpunkt von Nicolas Bewerbung
vergesse ich nicht.
Er war einer der wenigen Schüler,
der hierherkam und sagte:
"Ich will trotz Epilepsie
Polymechaniker lernen."
Der Entscheid war für ihn
in Stein gemeisselt.
Ich habe das gespürt
und ich habe das auch gut gefunden,
weil er seinem Handicap trotzte.
Für mich war klar,
dass wir ihm hier
eine Schnupperlehre bieten wollten.
Einmal fräsen, damit es
eine schöne Oberfläche gibt.
Mit der Taste holt er den Nullpunkt
und kann das Programm laufen lassen.
Das könnte von mir sein.
- Ja, aber ist von mir.
* Entspannte Gitarrenklänge *
Beim Wort Anfall
denken die meisten Leute:
Epileptiker,
die auf den Boden fallen,
im ganzen Körper Krämpfe haben,
aus dem Mund schäumen.
Das muss überhaupt nicht so sein.
Der Anfang ist das,
was ich noch mitbekomme.
Es ist ziemlich unangenehm,
ein komisches Gefühl.
Es ist unbeschreiblich. Man sieht
etwas, man spürt auch etwas.
Es ist ohne Verstand,
es gibt für mich keine Wörter.
Dann sehe ich noch etwas. Ich nehme
die Umgebung schon noch wahr.
Aber wenn ich in den Anfall hinein-
falle, ist es nur noch schwarz.
Ich nehme nichts mehr wahr.
Ich höre und sehe nichts mehr.
Es ist wie in einem Schlaf
ohne Traum.
Ein Anfall dauert normalerweise
zwischen einer halben
und einer ganzen Minute.
Irgendwann komme ich
wieder langsam zu mir.
Alles ist verschwommen. Ich fühle
mich benommen, bin extrem müde.
Ich habe Mühe mit reden.
Das kehrt langsam zurück.
Als Nicola 16 Jahre alt ist, treten
seine Anfälle zunehmend heftiger auf.
Es hat Szenen gegeben, als ich
auf dem Heimweg von der Schule war.
Ich bin am Bahnhof entlang gelaufen.
Im dümmsten Moment hatte ich einen
Anfall und bin aufs Gleis gefallen.
Zum Glück kam gerade kein Zug.
Mein Kumpel musste mich
vom Gleis hochheben.
Ich erinnere mich,
dass die Polizei da war.
Als ich unter der Dusche stand,
hat es öfters Stürze gegeben.
In der Badewanne ist es glitschig.
Es hat öfters Verletzungen gegeben,
am Kopf oder an der Nase.
Ich habe mich sehr gefreut, als
der Anruf kam und die Familie sagte:
"Wir wollen weitermachen, wir können
uns jetzt darauf einlassen
und überlegen,
dass er operiert werden kann."
"Jetzt sind wir dafür."
Oft sind es nicht mehr viele Worte,
man kennt sich ja auch gut.
Sie rufen an und sagen:
"Wir machen weiter."
Dann weiss man, was das heisst.
Auch Nicola war dann viel aktiver
und hat seinen Eltern Mut gemacht,
er habe keine Angst.
Er hat seinen Eltern auch gezeigt:
"Ich mache die Entscheidung
mit euch zusammen."
"Ihr seid nicht mehr die einzigen,
die das entscheiden müssen."
Eigentlich hat man sich dann
fast auf das Datum gefreut.
Das klingt komisch, aber es war
für uns quasi der Tag der Erlösung.
Im Sommer 2016 wird Nicola
von Spezialisten
der Neurochirurgischen Klinik
des Universitätsspital Zürich
operiert.
Zwei Eingriffe werden durchgeführt,
bei denen zuerst
der Anfallsursprung lokalisiert
und anschliessend das
epileptogene Gewebe entfernt wird.
Nicolas Chance auf Anfallsfreiheit
liegt bei etwa 70 %.
Jeden Tag, der ohne Anfall
über die Bühne gegangen ist,
hat man sich gefreut und gedacht:
"Wow! Wir sind dem Ziel
immer einen Schritt näher."
Für mich selbst ...
Ich habe mich nie richtig gefreut.
Ich habe gespürt,
dass irgendwo noch etwas ist.
Er war knapp vier Monate
komplett anfallsfrei.
Dann kamen erste ...
... Vorgefühle, die Aura kam zurück.
Neun Monate nach der Operation
kam dann der erste Anfall
wieder mit Bewusstseinsstörung.
* Vereinzelte, sanfte Klänge *
Die Phase, in welcher die Anfälle
wieder zurückkamen,
war einfach nur Horror.
Die ersten zwei Tage
war er nur im Zimmer.
Wir durften nicht mal rein
oder reden.
Und ...
Wir haben
mit dem Äussersten gerechnet.
Wir wussten nicht, wie das endet.
Bei dem Zusammenbruch
sind dann halt auch
starke Depressionen ausgebrochen.
Keine Lust mehr auf nichts,
keine Lebenslust mehr.
Man hat sich wirklich nur noch
nach dem Sinn des Lebens gefragt.
Wieso macht man das überhaupt?
Was bringt es überhaupt.
Am dritten Tag ist er runtergekommen
und hat mit uns geredet.
Er hat uns immer wieder -
wie soll ich sagen? - gezeigt:
"He, nein, es ist okay, ich bin da
und ich bin zum Kämpfen bereit."
"Ich gebe nicht auf."
* Schwere Klavierklänge *
Ist es zu heiss?
Die Unvorhersehbarkeit und der
Kontrollverlust durch die Anfälle
machen Nicola schwer zu schaffen.
Das Leben der ganzen Familie
wird auf eine harte Probe gestellt.
Als Nicol in Nicolas Leben tritt,
wird der Wunsch nach einem
selbstbestimmten, autonomen Leben
für den 19-Jährigen immer wichtiger.
In ihm reift der Entschluss, dass er
sich erneut operieren lassen will.
An der EPI-Klinik
wird in der Folge abgeklärt,
ob eine erneute Operation
überhaupt möglich ist.
Ein funktionelles MRI soll zeigen,
welche Hirnregion
bei einem weiteren operativen
Eingriff Schaden nehmen könnte.
Bei Nicola müssen wir genau schauen,
dass wir nicht zu nahe
an die Hirnregion kommen,
mit der wir Wortformen lesen können.
Wir können ja manchmal
ein ganzes Wort,
wenn man nur die Kontur sieht,
wie z.B. Auto ...
Das A ist prägnant, das T und das O.
Dann wissen wir,
das kann nur Auto heissen.
Diese Hirnregion ist nahe der
Region, wo wir schon operiert haben.
Da wollen wir relativ sicher sein,
dass wir ihm sagen können,
wie nahe wir an diese Region kommen,
wenn wir operieren,
oder wie nahe der Anfallsursprung
an dieser Region ist.
Und deshalb müssen noch
verschiedene Abklärungen passieren.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
* Schnuppern *
Es ist die zweite Operation,
die nun folgt.
Ich habe eigentlich
keine grossen Ängste.
Es ist eher mit Vorfreude
und Hoffnung verbunden.
Guten Abend zusammen.
Vielen Dank für eure Zeit,
dass wir das weitere Vorgehen
in der prächirurgischen Abklärung
bei Nicola Pfleghart
besprechen können.
Die involvierten Ärzte
tragen in einer Fallkonferenz
alle Auswertungen zusammen,
wägen Chancen und Risiken gegeneinan-
der ab und fällen ihre Entscheidung.
Wenn wir uns
auf den Vorschlag einigen,
sollten wir das noch mit den Neuro-
chirurgen das Risiko besprechen.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik,
Vogelzwitschern *
Ich persönlich mache mir im Moment
sicher weniger Gedanken,
wie es nachher sein wird,
was schlecht sein könnte.
Ich investiere die Kraft
mit Blick auf die Operation hin.
Ich gehe in einer gewissen
Kampfstimmung an die Sache heran
und schaue, wie es kommt.
* Nachdenkliche Klaviermusik *
Der Moment ist gekommen:
Heute erfährt Nicola
von seiner Ärztin Judith Kröll,
ob eine erneute Operation
möglich ist.
Guten Morgen.
- Grüezi.
Bei allen wichtigen Gesprächen
wird Nicola nebst seiner Mutter
auch von seinem Vater begleitet.
Dieser zieht es jedoch vor,
nicht vor die Kamera zu treten.
Du weisst, dass wir nach der
ersten Fallkonferenz gesagt haben,
wir müssten noch zwei Punkte klären.
Was der Chirurg sagt, war das eine.
Zudem möchten wir
noch genauer hinschauen,
wie nahe das Operationsgebiet
an der Hirnregion ist,
die für das Lesen von Wortformen
verantwortlich ist.
Jetzt ist einfach das Dilemma,
dass diese funktionelle Untersuchung
gezeigt hat,
dass diese Hirnregionen
ganz nahe dem Resektionsrand sind.
Der schlimmste Fall für dich wäre:
Du wirst durch die Operation
nicht anfallsfrei
und das Lesen wird für dich
noch mühsamer und noch schwieriger.
Also d.h., du kannst
deine Ausbildung nicht beenden.
Deshalb fanden alle Experten,
die zusammen waren,
es nicht den richtigen Zeitpunkt,
hier weiterzumachen.
Du musst verstehen können,
was es bedeutet,
wenn du Wortformen nicht mehr gut
lesen kannst, wenn das passiert.
Versuch deine Ausbildung, die noch
ein Jahr dauert, weiterzumachen.
Versuch,
die Ausbildung abzuschliessen.
Diese Zeit, die brauchst du jetzt
und die brauchen wir alle.
Und dann setzen wir uns
auch wieder zusammen.
Würde ich sagen,
das Risiko eingehen zu wollen ...
Würden wir zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
nicht empfehlen, das zu machen.
Ich unterschreibe alles,
was Sie wollen. - Das geht nicht.
Du möchtest die Anfälle loswerden,
das verstehen wir.
Und wenn ich das Lesen verliere -
das ist es mir wert.
Ja. - Ich würde noch viel mehr
Schaden auf mich nehmen.
Weisst du, wenn du nun
keine Ausbildung hast ...
Alle sagen immer, die Gesundheit sei
das Wichtigste, dann die Ausbildung.
Aber für
ein selbstständiges Leben ...
Würde es niemand tun?
Bei uns, in der jetzigen Situation:
nein!
Ich würde auch etwas dafür geben
und würde das Risiko eingehen.
Ein Chirurg hat nichts zu verlieren.
- Doch.
Der kriegt sein Geld.
Wir möchten alle nicht,
dass du einen Schaden davonträgst,
den wir
nicht mehr reparieren können.
Du leidest sehr unter den Auras.
Es ist keine Qualität, die ich habe.
Versuch einfach mal zu überlegen,
was das heisst,
wenn nun nicht
der gewünschte Erfolg eintritt.
Und dass zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
die Risiken schwerer wiegen
als die Nutzen.
Ich weiss es nicht. Ich würde
jedes Risiko eingehen. - Ich weiss.
Es braucht etwas Zeit,
um darüber nachzudenken.
Und das ist jetzt wirklich ...
Nimm ...
Gib dir Zeit!
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Und gib uns auch die Zeit.
Okay?
Mhm.
(Flüstern) Bin draussen.
* Eine Türe schliesst. *
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
* Einzelne,
höher werdende Klaviertöne *
Für Nicola
ist eine Welt zusammengebrochen,
zum zweiten Mal in einem Jahr.
Zum ersten Mal, als die Anfälle
wieder kamen, war es ganz schlimm.
Und jetzt steht er zum zweiten Mal
vor einem Trümmerhaufen.
Dem Wunsch von Nicola
jetzt nachzugeben,
egal, was passiert,
welches Defizit kommt ...
"Hauptsache, ihr operiert mich",
dem können wir nicht nachgeben.
Er kann diese Konsequenz
nicht voraussehen,
v.a. die doppelt negative
Konsequenz:
"Ich bekomme ein neues Defizit
und ich behalte die Anfälle."
Das ist auch realistisch.
Weil ein so hoher Leidensdruck
da ist, fällt es ihm schwer,
da nun die Waage zu halten.
Und deshalb könnte man
gar nicht zustimmen.
Das darf man nur,
wenn auch der Patient
die Konsequenzen versteht
und mit vorausdenken kann.
* Eintönige Klänge, Vogelzwitschern *
Die Zeit, seit der Nachricht,
dass es nicht geht,
ist extrem schwierig.
Aber jeden Tag, der vorbeigeht,
wird es ein wenig einfacher.
Er öffnet sich uns gegenüber wieder,
er isst mit uns.
Er verschanzt sich
nicht nur im Zimmer.
Manchmal redet er sogar mit uns.
Nicht über die Krankheit -
davon will er gar nichts hören.
Und er geht wieder arbeiten,
was ein sehr gutes Zeichen ist.
Ich wünsche mir einfach, dass er
wieder auf Kurs kommt und weiss,
was wichtig ist für ihn.
* Hecheln *
An der Epilepsie
hat sich gar nichts geändert.
Ich habe immer noch meine Anfälle.
Ich nehme immer
noch meine Medikamente.
Es geht ums Akzeptieren.
Ich muss leben damit.
Ich muss eine Perspektive finden,
damit ich das überstehe.
Im Moment ist es noch machbar.
Dank der Unterstützung von
Freundschaften, Familie, Freundin.
Es gibt Momente, in denen ich es
auch gut vergessen kann,
die schön sind.
Es vergehen drei schwierige Monate,
in denen Nicola
heftige Anfälle erleidet.
Innerhalb von zwei Wochen bricht er
sich bei Stürzen in der Unterführung
und im Wald zweimal den Kiefer
und verliert insgesamt acht Zähne.
Der Leidensdruck wird immer grösser.
Nicola entscheidet sich,
an der EPI-Klinik psychiatrische
Hilfe in Anspruch zu nehmen.
Dank den Gesprächen,
die du mit Herrn Schmutz hattest,
bist du wieder offener geworden,
die Behandlung anzunehmen.
Du hast einfach
diese Blockade abgelegt.
Du bist auch bereit gewesen,
um wieder neue Untersuchungen
in Angriff zu nehmen.
Das war der Start für die Phase,
in der wir uns jetzt befinden.
Nicola drängt
auf weitere Untersuchungen.
Aufgrund der hohen Verletzungsgefahr
durch Stürze
prüfen die Ärzte erneut die Möglich-
keit eines operativen Eingriffs.
Das Risiko einer Leseschwäche
als Folge der Operation
ist allerdings hoch.
Ich kann schon so weiterleben
und Medikamente einnehmen,
die nichts bringen.
Früher oder später bin ich gelähmt,
wenn ich immer mehr Unfälle habe.
Und, ja, dann sind es mir
diese 50 % schon wert. Ja.
* Eindringliche Klaviermusik *
Die behandelnde Ärztin
erklärt Nicola,
dass die Operation
nur dann durchführbar ist,
wenn die Anfälle von einer eindeutig
lokalisierbaren Stelle kämen.
Wie zwei Jahre zuvor
planen die Ärzte, zuerst
Tiefenelektroden zu implantieren,
welche Nicolas Hirnströme
während der Anfälle
detailliert aufzeichnen sollen.
Am Universitätsspital Zürich
erklärt Chirurg Niklaus Krayenbühl,
der Nicola bereits 2016 operiert hat,
den Eingriff in allen Details.
Das hier ist einfach eine Elektrode,
die wir hier aufs Hirn legen.
Damit können wir herausfinden,
wo sich die Anfälle
nach oben hin ausbreiten.
Dieses Mal dürfen Sie
grosszügiger schneiden.
Ja, ich weiss natürlich schon,
für die Betroffenen gilt:
Hauptsache, es ist weg.
Das Beste wäre, wenn es dir so gut
gehen würde wie jetzt, ohne Anfälle.
Das ist das Ziel.
- Das wäre optimal so, ja.
Das nehmen wir - ja, gerne.
Das wollen wir auch erreichen.
- Ja.
Meine einzige Frage:
Wann ist der Termin?
* Lachen *
Er ist reif und würde sich
am liebsten gleich hinlegen.
Okay, gut.
- Vielen Dank!
Frau Pfleghart, alles Gute.
- Ihnen auch, merci.
Darf ich Nicola sagen?
- Ja, ja. Machen Sie nur.
Okay.
Gut, gut.
- Gut, oder?
Super!
Am frühen Morgen des 6. August 2018
werden am Universitätsspital Zürich
die Tiefenelektroden implantiert.
* Rasche, pulsierende Musik *
Ta-taa!
Passt!
Er hat Elektroden
implantiert bekommen,
damit wir ein EEG
aus dem Hirn ableiten können.
Wir haben geplant,
verschiedene Elektroden im Gewebe zu
implantieren, was nicht einfach ist,
weil es viele Blutgefässe im Gehirn
gibt, die man umfahren möchte.
Darum habe ich hier Wege gesucht,
die wir millimetergenau
einhalten müssen,
um die Elektroden
sicher zu platzieren.
* Surren *
61 mm.
So, wie dick ist hier unser Knochen?
- Haben wir vermessen ...
* Surren *
Die Elektroden sind stumpf.
Liegt in der Tiefe
ein Blutgefäss auf dem Weg,
geht das Blutgefäss in der Regel
zur Seite und es passiert nichts.
Probleme machen uns Blutgefässe
auf der Hirnoberfläche.
Sie sind an der Hirnhaut fest.
Mache ich dort ein Bohrloch, was ich
im Prinzip alles blind mache,
muss ich mich
darauf verlassen können,
dass kein Blutgefäss da ist,
das nicht ausweichen kann.
* Langgezogener Piepton *
Ich habe zur Kontrolle die
postoperative Computertomographie
mit den Elektroden hier.
Wir sehen, dass wir
im vorderen Hippocampus
auf der linken Seite
zwei, fast drei Kontakte drin haben.
Hier liegt eine Tiefenelektrode
sehr schön an der Randzone.
Rundum zufrieden. Genau.
* Sanfte Klänge,
Piepsen im Hintergrund *
* Einzelne Klaviertöne *
Am Tag nach der Operation
erholt sich Nicola
von den Strapazen des Eingriffs.
Zurück an der EPI-Klinik
schöpft er neue Kraft.
Meine grösste Hoffnung ist
natürlich, dass man operieren kann,
dass alles gut funktioniert,
auch mit dem Monitoring.
Und wenn das funktioniert,
dann bin ich eigentlich glücklich.
Es ist noch etwas ein Durchhalten
und auf die Zähne beissen,
aber wenn man schlussendlich
mit Erfolg operieren kann,
war es das alles wert.
* Elektronische Musik *
Bevor Nicolas Anfälle
aufgezeichnet werden können,
müssen die implantierten Elektroden
nach einem genauen Schema
mit dem Computersystem
verbunden werden.
Zusätzlich werden
Oberflächenelektroden angebracht.
* Verschiedene
elektronische Geräusche *
Bei der ersten OP
habe ich einen Fehler gemacht.
Ich habe mich zu sehr
in die Hoffnung gestürzt.
Das darf ich nicht mehr machen,
sonst ist es nachher -
wenn es ein Misserfolg
sein sollte -,
wieder ein Sturz, den ich
nicht noch einmal erleben will.
Darum bleibe ich jetzt
zuversichtlich,
aber noch realistisch.
Makro LL 60.
L.
PL, ja?
Geht's noch?
Elf, ja?
- Ja.
* Stimmengewirr *
* Sanfte Klavierklänge, gemischt
mit schneller, elektronischer Musik *
* Stimmengewirr *
Wir sind hier im Intensivmonitoring.
Wir überwachen die Patienten 24 Std.
Wir haben Nicola hier
mit implantierten Elektroden.
Wir schauen nach den Veränderungen
im EEG und warten auf Anfälle.
* Sie reden durcheinander. *
Wir haben das EEG, das läuft. Meis-
tens sind es Oberflächenelektroden.
Bei Nicola ist es speziell, weil wir
implantierte Elektroden haben
und zusätzlich läuft Tag und Nacht
ein Video mit.
Der optimale Ablauf wäre,
wenn ich heute zwei, drei,
vier, fünf Anfälle hätte.
Dann könnten sie sich das anschauen
und ich wäre hier
möglichst schnell wieder raus.
Klingt komisch, aber es ist so.
Möglichst schnell
möglichst viele Anfälle.
Es vergehen vier endlose Tage -
ohne Anfälle.
Erst nachdem die Medikamentendosis
stark reduziert wird,
folgen die ersehnten Anfälle.
Sobald Nicola einen Anfall hat,
sieht man das am EEG am besten.
Dann hat es pathologische
Veränderungen, bzw. einen Ablauf.
Merken Sie sich das Wort Haus.
Sobald Nicola einen Anfall hat,
gehen wir sofort rein
und machen spezielle Tests.
Wir fragen ihn.
Testen, was er kann, was geht.
Sprache, Motorik. Gedächtnis.
* Düstere Musik *
Nach sechs Tagen
im Intensivmonitoring
informiert die Ärztin Nicola,
ob die ersehnte Operation
nun durchgeführt werden kann.
* Klopfen *
Grüezi.
- Hallo.
Grüezi erst einmal.
So, ich nehme mir mal
einen Stuhl dazu.
Ich denke, das Warten hat sich
auf jeden Fall gelohnt.
Sind Sie fündig geworden?
- Genau, wir sind fündig geworden.
Wir sind in der grossen Runde
zusammengesessen,
haben alles angeschaut
und uns genaue Gedanken gemacht.
Als Erstes kann man sagen,
dass wir genügend Anfälle haben.
Die vier grossen Anfälle zeigen uns,
dass sie auf der linken Seite sind,
aber sie zeigen uns nicht
den unmittelbaren Anfallsursprung.
Aber alles zusammen
spricht nicht gegen eine Operation.
Aber, weil es halt
nicht so schön eng begrenzt ist,
wie man sich das gerne
gewünscht hätte,
mit einer eher schlechteren Chance
auf Anfallsfreiheit.
Oh.
Sagen wir unterdurchschnittlich.
Aber wir glauben schon,
dass Sie mit der OP
tatsächlich eine Chance haben,
dass die Anfälle aufhören könnten
oder deutlich weniger werden.
Risiko für Sie:
Die Dyslexie, d.h. die Lesefähigkeit
wird wahrscheinlich
tatsächlich schlechter werden.
Damit müssen Sie rechnen.
- Oh.
Ja.
Ich würde es trotzdem machen wollen.
Das ist eine Entscheidung,
die nur Sie treffen können.  - Ja.
Eine schwere Entscheidung.
All diese Aussagen
sind eigentlich top.
Mehr kann ich mir nicht wünschen.
Es ist halt das, was nachher kommt,
irgendwie das ...
Die Chance auf einen Erfolg
ist doch nicht mehr so gross,
wie man sie sich gewünscht hat.
Der Schaden, den es geben könnte,
ist doch etwas grösser.
Die Möglichkeit, aber ...
Schlussendlich hat man dann doch
definitiv alles versucht.
Morgen ist der Tag,
an welchem endlich die dritte und
definitive Operation stattfindet.
Bei dieser ganzen Geschichte ...
Wenn man das alles macht, ist
das Vertrauen den Ärzten gegenüber
wahrscheinlich
etwas vom Wichtigsten.
Mein Chriurg, der Krayenbühl,
ist ein Toptyp.
Er ist mega sympathisch.
Er ist Zürcher, das gefällt mir.
Ja, ein bisschen Kind
darf man bleiben.
Ab in die Ferien!
Ich habe sieben Nächte
im Unispital gebucht.
Abflug.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
... und rennt wie ...
* Die Musik
übertönt das Gesprochene. *
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
(Leise) Mach's gut!
* Schluchzen *
Die Heulerei hilft nicht, ich weiss.
Etwas Humor musst du behalten.
- Hm?
Etwas Humor musst du haben.
- Ja.
Nein!
* Unverständliche Worte *
* Motor startet. *
* Sanfte, ansteigende Klavierklänge *
* Sanfte Klavierklänge,
Stimmengewirr *
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
* Piepsen *
(Mann) Tief Luft holen,
Herr Pfleghart, wenn es geht.
(Frau) Tief einatmen,
Herr Pfleghart.
Bis später!
- Bis nachher.
Eins, zwei, drei. So ist es gut.
Epilepsie.
Ursprung: Temper-Occipital.
Das gibt eine erweiterte
Läsionektomie mit Rekraniotomie
mit interoperativem ECOG.
Christian, kann ich?
- Ja, du kannst.
Schweizweit werden
in unterschiedlichen Spitälern
jährlich rund 80 epilepsie-
chirurgische Eingriffe durchgeführt.
Am Unispital Zürich
schon seit über 80 Jahren.
Aufgrund der Fortschritte
in der Neurochirurgie
sind sie sehr sicher geworden.
Und dennoch: Jeder Eingriff am Hirn
stellt ein Risiko dar.
Der erfahrene Chirurg Niklaus
Krayenbühl muss stets abwägen,
wie viel Gewebe er entfernt.
Einen Millimeter zu viel,
und der Patient könnte
eine wichtige Hirnfunktion verlieren.
Die Operation an und für sich ist
für die Sprachfunktion sehr riskant.
Nicht einfach das Reden,
aber das Sprachverständnis,
der Ausdruck, der Redefluss, das
Erkennen von Wörtern, Gegenständen.
Das Risiko ist schon
durch die Operation selbst gegeben.
Wären wir aber dort
noch weitergegangen,
wäre das Risiko, nicht mehr
sprechen zu können, sehr gross.
Haben wir
eine schwarze Referenzelektrode?
Unterer Teil lateral, oder?
Fünf ist der Oberteil lateral.
Unsere Funktion
von der EPI-Klinik ist,
dass wir hier
den Operateur unterstützen.
Währen der Operation
leiten wir das EEG ab.
Hinsichtlich der Operationsgrenzen
können wir sagen,
wo genau
Epilepsie-typische Potenziale
in welchem Ausmass auftreten.
So geben wir dem Operateur
einen Anhalt,
wo denn der Schwerpunkt
der Operation stattfinden soll
und wie ausgedehnt
die Operation werden wird.
Bei ihm ist es wegen der vielen
Blutgefässe rundum sehr heikel.
Hier fliesst ein Grossteil vom Blut
ab vom linken Schläfenlappen.
Und wenn das verletzt ist,
hat er auch einen Sprachausfall.
* Surren *
Er sagte, lieber mehr rausnehmen,
die Funktion sei egal,
Hauptsache keine Anfälle mehr.
Es ist für den Patienten schwierig,
abzuschätzen, was es heisst,
wirklich nicht reden zu können.
Das ist ein Riesenhandicap,
das ich ihm in dem Alter
nicht zumuten möchte.
Die Vier
ist im unteren Teil lateral.
Im Vergleich zu vorher super.
* Surren *
* Nervöse Musik *
Die Operation dauerte etwa 4 Std.,
so wie geplant.
Wir haben noch einmal
in einem zweiten Versuch ...
Wir haben versucht,
den Epilepsieherd zu entfernen.
Teilweise hat man
verändertes Gewebe gesehen,
teilweise war es sehr schwierig,
weil die Stelle sehr heikel ist.
Aufgrund der Risiken,
was die Sprache betrifft,
haben wir entschieden,
so aufzuhören.
Jetzt hoffen wir,
dass es ihm gut geht.
* Verschiedene Piepgeräusche *
(Mann) Tief atmen!
Tief atmen. Die Operation ist
fertig, es ist alles gut gegangen.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
* Eindringliche Klänge *
Irgendwie sieht es noch cool aus.
Ich weiss nicht warum, aber ...
Aber irgendwie
sieht es beängstigend aus.
Wenn man sich vorstellt,
dass da ein Schnitt war
und etwas am Hirn gemacht wurde.
Danke.
- Bitte.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Es beginnt sicher ein neues Leben
oder ein neues Kapitel,
wenn jetzt alles erfolgreich war.
Wenn wirklich die Anfallsfreiheit
da ist, freue ich mich,
dass wir Sachen machen können,
die wir bisher nicht konnten.
Also dass er nun z.B. auch
mit mir schwimmen kann.
Rad fahren.
- Rad fahren könnten wir.
Ich fahre mit dem Auto.
Er könnte lernen, Auto zu fahren.
Vielleicht kannst du es vor mir
und du bringst es mir bei.
Ja, mal schauen.
Dass man einfach sorgloser wird.
Dass man nicht die ganze Zeit
bereit sein muss,
dass etwas kommt.
Diese Anspannung ist weniger.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Salü!
- Hallo!
Hoi. Schon wieder Giottos.
- Ja, sicher.
Hoi!
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Aha, er macht ein Schweizer Video.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge, Wortfetzen *
Ich weiss nicht,
ob das meine Familie ist.
* Die Musik
übertönt das Gesprochene. *
* Sanfte Klaviermusik,
stille Szenen *
* Langgezogener, tiefer Klavierton *
* Kreischen,
lockere Gitarrenklänge *
* Schwungvolle Musik *
Es sind jetzt vier Monate vergangen,
seit die Operation war.
Seither bin ich anfallsfrei.
Es ist schon ein befreiteres Gefühl.
Was Lesen allgemein betrifft:
Es ist wirklich null und nichts
verloren gegangen.
Ich kann immer noch
gleich gut lesen wie vorher.
Ich bin seit etwa zehn Jahren
nicht mehr Rad gefahren.
War es lustig?
- Es war angenehm.
Dass du Panaschee trinkst!
- Es ist fein.
Hattest du schon mal?
- Ja.
Okay, gut.
Auf das Happy End!
Pröstchen!
* Lockere Musik *
Die Nachkontrollen an der EPI-Klinik
und am Universitätsspital Zürich
zeigen ein erfreuliches Ergebnis.
Jetzt im Moment ist es einfach mega.
Ich kann es nicht anders sagen.
Es war ein langer Weg.
Und jetzt ist einfach
eine Erleichterung da.
Nicola hat seit der Operation
keine Anfälle mehr,
nicht einmal mehr
ein epileptisches Gefühl im Kopf.
All die Auras sind weg.
Die Ängste, die da waren ...
Die Defizite, die nach der Operation
hätten auftreten können,
wie nicht mehr lesen oder sehen,
hat er nicht.
Dafür sind wir natürlich
sehr dankbar.
* Möwen kreischen, lockere Musik *
Die letzten paar Male packte ich
die Koffer, um ins Spital zu gehen,
für Aufenthalte,
Untersuchungen und Operationen.
In Zukunft werde ich
die Koffer packen für unsere Ferien,
für unsere Ausflüge.
Ich hoffe, dass das so bleiben wird.
Schau, der dicke Vogel.
* Lockere Musik, Kreischen *
Ich sehe, dass uns diese Zeit auch
viel mehr zusammengeschweisst hat.
Wir mussten als Team funktionieren.
Und jetzt hoffen wir natürlich,
dass wir ihn wirklich in die
Selbstständigkeit entlassen können,
dass er in die Welt gehen
und seinen Weg machen kann.
In den folgenden sieben Monaten
kann sich Nicola voll und ganz
seiner Ausbildung widmen -
befreit von der Angst vor Anfällen
und mit einem festen Ziel vor Augen.
Im Sommer schliesst Nicola
seine Ausbildung zum Polymechaniker
erfolgreich ab.
Auch über ein Jahr nach der Operation
ist er anfallsfrei.
* Lockere Gitarrenmusik *